un bâtiment de 3000 m² anéanti douze
mille mètres cubes de poussière de
céréales de paille et de luzerne se sont
embrasés les premières équipes de
sapeurs pompiers arrivés dans la nuit
ont d'abord lutter contre la propagation
d'un incendie
quarante cinq hommes étaient présents au
plus fort du sinistre dont l'objectif
pour nous était de protéger le bâtiment
derrière qui est un bâtiment industriel
et dans l'outil de production de
l'exploitant c'est un feu que nous avons
circonscrit c'est à dire qu'il est
limitée aujourd'hui à l'enveloppé du
bâtiment du bâtiment que nous voyons
derrière toutefois au vu des
températures actuelles et du vin qui va
se renforcer de la fable hydrométrie des
végétaux aux alentours nous sommes
limités pour l'instant au déblai un
cours non seulement les pompiers ont
lutté contre le feu présents sur le site
mais ce dernier aurait pu à tout moment
se propager rapidement cultures
avoisinantes
compte tenu de la nature des matières
enflammé beaucoup de brandon inflammé
sont venus se poser sur le toit ici et
ont enflammé toute la paille toute la
poussière qui était sur ce toit nous
avons même des bretons qui ont sauté la
zone et qui sont allés à plus de 200
mètres dans un champ de blé pour pour
faire un départ de feu un groupe d'une
quinzaine d'hommes va rester sur place
pendant les prochaines 24 heures les
pompiers comptent profiter de l'humidité
de la nuit pour éteindre l'incendié et
le maîtriser complètement